Jan Cammie University of Western Ontario
who actually is just a few weeks ago
announced the discovery of c60 molecules
and c70 in interstellar space amazing I
call it the third man actually you know
third man orson welles lurking in the
shadows and the sewers of Vienna as the
staff to the war a shady character and
then the light goes on in an upstairs
window and you see Austin wells for the
first time in that movie and the c60 is
the third form of carbon certainly the
third well-defined form of carbon and
it's been lurking in the galaxy ever
since well probably Carmen came out of a
carbon star and it's still got a few
puzzles for us and disappears again is
it responsible for the diffuses into
stellar bands I think it probably is and
a question three you have suggested that
the forey's might play a key role in
solving and not all this trinomial
problem the diffuses to cell bands what
are your current thoughts about the
carriers of the diffuse bends what I
should have read it before I like to
answer questions spontaneously than I
don't get confused in this case I've
half answered it when we discovered c60
a second reason for doing the experiment
was to try to show that carbon molecules
were involved in a puzzle that's been a
problem for 90 years
some diffused bands in the interstellar
medium and I many others think carbons
involved and I think it must be we did
the experiment partly as a stepping
stone to a more complex experiment to
show that perhaps these bands which are
seen all over the place they're called
the diffuse interstellar bands might be
carbon chains an idea put forward by
Alec Douglas fir and of my new is the
National Research Council on friend of
many astronomers many years ago we never
got to do that expert
because c60 turned up and diverted our
attention but my feeling is it's coming
out of stars out of carbon stars and
therefore it's been around all the time
and here is this material which is all
over the place many many stars seen
towards red and objects whether the dust
and carbon does presumably you see these
features and none of them have been
identified and we done spectroscopy in
150 years reading we've done a lot of
spectroscopy of every molecule and you
know not to single features been
detected yet here is C 60 this amazing
character the third man lurking in the
galaxy all these years and we've only
just discovered it so it seems highly
plausible to suggest that some C 60
derivative is involved now it could be a
hydrogen molecule or I my feeling is
it's a charge transfer the spectrum
wasted metal atom can stick to it or
some atom and have these features though
my colleague John Meyer and Basel
suggested it be very broad which is
probably true so I think it's either end
ahed rule C 60 either C 60 with an atom
on the inside or C 60 with some atoms
attached in some way to it it's just too
strong a circumstantial wall sort of
situation now they've been seen for 90
years we don't know what they are we
don't know that never haven't seen these
things on earth and yet C 60 been
lurking around on earth that I say is
also in Bunsen burner flames and we've
only just found it so I think the
diffusion to bound interstellar bands I
think the numbers nearly up I think it
well I would do believe that it C 60 was
involved in some way